(hip hop music)
Kelly: I've never seen this.
This has been so impressive and amazing,
and leaving teachers with wanting more.
(hip hop music)
Joshua: When I first
knew about Khan Academy,
it was mostly like, "Uh, my
teacher said this in class,
"but I can't remember what he said,
"so I'm going to go check
out on Khan Academy."
So, it was more of a personal resource,
and that's kinda where I
was thinking it would be
in my classroom down the line, and say,
"If you're struggling with this,
"go check out Khan Academy."
But now, after coming to this,
it can be that first step.
It can be the go-to, "Hey, go learn this,
"go learn the foundations,"
and then we can take it
to the next level in our classroom.
We can put those hands-on activities.
(hip hop music)
David: [Thinking] it will take a child,
and look and say, "Wow, they're
really struggling here,"
so, now when I've got
everybody else doing this,
I can slip around back
without anybody noticing
that I'm helping somebody
because they're slower
and allowing that child
to keep their dignity,
because I was able to privately
identify what there was
that they needed help
with; and that was awesome.
(hip hop music)
Jeannie: I love this whole concept.
This is so life-changing
in the way that you teach,
because then it gives you
time to work with the students
and it gives you time to
understand what they know
and clear up misconceptions.
It gives you time to just really encourage
those students to go on.
(hip hop music)
Teri: I have a very
unique set of students.
They happen to be behind bars.
In my classroom, I might have a guy
that's functioning at his 2nd grade level,
and I may have a guy that has his PhD,
sitting in the same classroom,
and how do you bridge
that gap as a teacher?
And yet, I saw the Khan
Academy being a tool
that we could implement at a very low cost
with our economy the way it is
and provide the biggest bang for the buck.
(hip hop music)
David: Empowering the student to learn
is what the key is to
making them learn for life,
so I think this is a great
aspect and a great tool of that,
and I think it'll actually
start helping them to say,
"Hey, if I don't know the
answer, I can find it."
Because that's kinda what I
try to do in my classroom,
and I think we need to do more of that.
Al: It's the way kids learn now.
It's the way kind of education is going.
It's been kind of status
quo for many years now,
and I think that we really
are on the front edge
of some new, innovative
solutions to helping kids learn,
and catching up, with not
only the rest of the nation,
but the rest of the world.
Kelly: I feel like my students
are the [revolutioni].
(hip hop music)